you need to know about a fatal auto  pedestrian rollover crash this is from  about two o'clock this morning Sahara is  completely closed between paradise and  Maryland Parkway because of this crash  right here that's from the Regional  Transportation Commission we have our  own camera on the scene as well let's  take a look at that and there is that  rolled over vehicle no word on exactly  how this went down or how long the road  is going to be closed but back to the  traffic computer to show you how to get  around this Sahara again shut down  Paradise to Maryland Parkway go up to St  Louis there's Karen right to the South  or all the way down to Di